[Music]
on this saturday night the u.s strike on
isis-k
two high-profile isis targets
were killed
and one was wounded as the taliban adds
reinforcements at the kabul airport
security concerns on the campaign trail
after a protest shuts down a liberal
rally
the push for indigenous candidates we
are committed to making sure our
parliament looks like canada
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us u.s president joe biden warns another
terrorist attack is likely at cabell's
airport and he promises the united
states will follow through with more
retaliatory action
yesterday the american military
conducted a drone strike on what it
described as an isis-k planner the
terrorist group is behind this week's
suicide bombing that killed members of
the u.s military and civilians trying to
escape from afghanistan as redmond
shannon reports it's become a hopeless
situation for those left behind
more panic and confusion near kabul
airport
amid warnings of a new security threat
this time the gunfire and tear gas were
just to disperse the crowds
britain and france have now stopped
their evacuations in advance of the u.s
withdrawal tuesday i'm afraid it's
absolutely heartbreaking that we can't
bring everybody out
[Music]
mostly u.s evacuations continue as the
hours run down before the taliban takes
control of the airport area at the
airport in washington details of the
retaliation for thursday's horrific
bombing a drone strike killing what the
pentagon says were two members of isis
courtesan they were isis k planners and
facilitators
and that's enough reason
they're alone
the threat of isis k adds to the
jeopardy faced by western citizens and
afghans eligible to leave the country
the canadian government is still trying
to figure out how many are left behind
global news spoke to a former canadian
forces interpreter who was in a safe
house in kabul his family of six in one
room
we were a canadian task force for
special forces interpreters and workers
and all my quarter all of them are left
to behind this is unfair this is unfair
it makes me cry
he and his family had been standing
where the bomb went off just a day
before the explosion he knows at least
one man who was killed he was moving to
canada
he's dead for men i think he was a
barber
parking against troops
[Music]
he told us he knows of 30 other families
in hiding in kabul following the end of
canada's evacuations
to go to pakistan all the borders are
blocked nothing we can do
we don't know our life what is going on
where our life is going i will try my
best to get pakistan and i pray to god
to get pakistan in a safe situation none
of them are sure what comes next all are
pleading to ottawa for help redmond
shannon global news london
the canadian government maintains it is
working around the clock to help get
afghans to safety let's join our auto
bureau chief mercedes stevenson and
mercedes you just spoke with the foreign
affairs minister what did he say canada
is doing
i did robin and that's been the big
question we wanted to know from the
minister for this week's edition of the
west block he says that canada is
beginning negotiations with the taliban
this had been a big question mark
because as you may remember canada's
embassy closed down and completely
pulled out which meant there was no one
left on the ground to carry out
negotiations with the taliban until the
military got there and we don't know
whether or not they were engaged but one
of the questions people were asking is
whether we were able to talk to the
taliban about getting canadian citizens
and afghans who had helped canada out
safely a negotiation the french and
others had made this is what foreign
affairs minister mark garneau told me
about canada's plans going forward
that is happening in the days ahead of
us and a
priority demand in fact it's the number
one demand is that they allow safe
passage of afghans out of the country uh
that is something that everybody agrees
with and that we will be
establishing as a demand on the on the
taliban as we move forward we don't know
how they're going to react to that but
that is a primary uh focus uh in the
days to come in speaking with the
taliban
so robin that is news that the canadian
government is going to begin
negotiations with the taliban they say
that turkey and qatar two countries are
also negotiating with the taliban to try
to take control of the air space around
the airport which would allow it to
reopen for commercial flights
mercedes what about the people still on
the ground what efforts are being made
to help them
well that really is the biggest question
at this point it's mostly veterans
groups who are carrying this out i've
talked to veterans who tell me that they
are putting their personal savings into
this some who are
selling off things like motorcycles to
be able to pay for safe houses for
canadians to stay in and for afghans who
helped canada
the foreign affairs minister would not
commit to whether or not the government
will directly fund those efforts they
are telling people not to lose hope that
they are trying to find a way to get
them out but in the meantime in this
moment it's really the veterans groups
and the ngos that are trying to keep
people there safe
as they figure out what the next steps
are going to be going forward to get
people out robert mercedes stephenson in
ottawa and mercedes will bring you the
full interview with the foreign affairs
minister that's tomorrow on the west
block here on global
canadians and people around the world
are coming together to call attention to
the crisis in afghanistan
rallies were held in several cities
across this country today protesters
gathered in downtown montreal to demand
an end to the conflict demonstrations
were also held in cities across europe
hundreds marched in london against the
taliban rallies in support of afghans
were also held in paris and greece
turning to the federal election tonight
the issues are taking a back seat to
security on the campaign trail last
night the liberal party had to cancel an
event with its leader unruly
anti-vaccine protesters showed up at a
stop in bolton ontario as michael
couture reports justin trudeau says he's
never seen anything like it
there are political protests and then
there's this
dozens of angry demonstrators gathered
at a liberal campaign stop in bolton
ontario it got so tense the event had to
be cancelled because of safety concerns
later at a different location justin
trudeau called for calm this is
something that canadians
all of us
need to reflect on
because it's not because it's not who we
are
it's not who we want to be as a country
late friday the conservative candidate
for the riding trudeau was visiting
tweeted that a few of his supporters
were at that protest kyle seebach said
those people are no longer welcome on
his campaign conservative leader erin
o'toole says he's running a positive
campaign and there's nothing positive
about what those volunteers did there is
no positive reason and if they were they
will no longer be involved with our
campaign
full stop
saturday drug meet singh's election bus
was held up briefly by a protester who
refused to let the vehicle pass earlier
in the day the ndp leader reflected on
the divisive discourse that has
overshadowed some of this campaign
in some cases political leaders attack
another
colleague just for the attack sake where
the attack is just to put someone down
that i think is not helpful some feel
the donald trump era south of the border
sparked the type of profanity-laced
politics we're now seeing during this
election campaign people now feel that
they
they're entitled to to have their
emotions and their anger put out there
to to prevent other people from having a
political speech or a gathering the
liberal campaign was on a previously
scheduled day off saturday but trudeau's
team says friday night's protest will
not change how he campaigns over the
next three weeks
robin michael couture on the campaign
trail thanks mike
at his campaign stop in fredericton this
morning conservative leader aaron
o'toole promised to help make life more
affordable
if you and your family aren't concerned
about rising prices well you have four
parties to choose from in this election
o'toole says his government would
increase competition and lower food
prices the conservative leader is
promising to increase the maximum
penalty for price fixing to a hundred
million dollars and introduce criminal
penalties including jail time
ndp leader jack meet singh spent the
morning in sudbury ontario visiting the
university of sudbury where he pledged
to do away with interest on student
loans and to forgive student debt
we also know that students are dealing
with record levels of debt far more debt
than any of us when we went to
university i remember when i went to law
school and my tuition fees are nothing
compared to what they are right now and
people are struggling students are
struggling when they graduate
the party's campaign platform pledges to
do away with up to 20 000 in debt which
would help close to 350 000 students
the new democrats are trying to make
gains with another critical segment of
the electorate the indigenous community
the party is campaigning hard in
northern parts of the country ridings
that are separated by huge distances but
as our chief political correspondent
david aiken reports these writings have
a significant indigenous population and
for the ndp capturing more of that vote
is key
one two three
ndp leader judgment singh got a warm
welcome when he touched down in the
northern ontario riding of kenora it's a
writing where more than 40 percent of
voters are indigenous and where many
remote and isolated communities are not
keen to see campaigning outsiders in a
pandemic we're coming emerging out of a
pandemic some people
are quite hesitant to be close and to
have me come to their residence seymour
is running in a riding the size of
germany but that's not unique there are
lots of federal and provincial ridings
so big much campaigning has to be done
by plane that's the the challenge that
we have and do we have the resources to
be able to do that
seymour is one of 25 indigenous people
running for the ndp in this election and
the party is making a special effort to
support them with dedicated staff and
dedicated financial resources we are
committed to making sure our parliament
looks like canada and particularly
helping those that have been
excluded from the halls of power have
been denied access to decision making
singh's attention to that effort is
winning praise from non-partisan first
nations leaders i think that on a
personal level he's a tremendous leader
regardless of the flag that flies behind
him i i always i always support strong
leadership sound leadership
manitoba ndp leader wab canoe is one of
just a handful of indigenous people to
ever lead a major provincial party in
canada i know representation matters to
young people but i hope everyone in
canada
recognizes how much representation
matters because for too long
people from some of our communities
weren't being represented in some of the
halls of power
lots of canada's big northern ridings
are in play in this election yukon
nunavut northern saskatchewan a couple
in northern quebec and here in northern
ontario and they all have lots of
indigenous voters that are looking to
all the parties to address their issues
and their priorities and if it's a close
election and it looks like it just might
be well those votes could make a big
difference robin david aiken in thunder
bay ontario thanks david still ahead
people are getting poisoned by taking a
medicine meant for farm animals
canada is suspending direct passenger
flights from morocco because of surging
kova 19 cases transport canada cites an
increase in positive test results in
travelers arriving here from morocco
over the last month the restriction will
go into effect at midnight and remain in
place for 30 days
doctors in the u.s are battling a
surprising epidemic a rash of poisonings
patients infected with covet 19 are
self-medicating with a drug meant for
livestock as jackson proskow reports
it's just the latest unproven cure being
pushed by anti-vaxxers
in the u.s south the worst days of the
pandemic have brought along an outbreak
of self-inflicted illness it just
doesn't make sense it doesn't make sense
to risk your life or your health to take
unproven medications 70 percent of the
calls to poison control in mississippi
now involve people who've taken huge
doses of ivermictin falsely believing it
can prevent covid the benefits of a drug
called ivermectin touted as a miracle
prevention and cure by far-right
commentators and anti-vaxxers ivermitten
is a treatment for lice and tropical
parasites not viruses with doctors
unwilling to prescribe it for kovid
people have rushed to farm supply stores
buying and taking large doses meant to
deworm livestock some are ending up in
hospital the doses that we give humans
is three milligrams and six milligrams
and the doses that you can get for cows
and cattle is 60 100 200 many many fold
higher you are not a horse you are not a
cow warned the food and drug
administration in a tweet this week
responding to a flurry of online
misinformation about the drug
a lot of missing disinformation has a uh
central kernel of truth so there is a
clinical trial to see hey is this really
going to work but
there's nothing really proven at this
point it's it's purely sort of
speculation the hydroxychloroquine
coupled with the zinc the frenzy is
reminiscent of former president donald
trump's promotion of anti-malarial drugs
and bleach as cures injection inside
or
almost a cleaning which also led to
poisonings you're right to draw a line
between hydroxychloroquine and
ivermectin i'm having some of those same
conversations with some of the same
people the difference now is that
vaccines are widely available studied
and proven effective
experts warn these false cures are not
only unnecessary they're misleading
delivering nothing more than a dose of
dangerous consequences
jackson proskow global news washington
a storm is coming still ahead louisiana
braces for the worst as hurricane ida
approaches
you're watching global national
[Music]
hurricane ida hit cuba late friday with
winds over 120 kilometers per hour trees
were toppled and there are still
concerns about flooding as much as 50
centimeters of rain fell
ida is now picking up strength as it
travels through the gulf of mexico it's
expected to hit louisiana tomorrow
evening potentially as a
life-threatening category 4 hurricane
the wind speed
at landfall
is projected to be sustained in the
neighborhood of 140 miles per hour
this is a very strong
storm this will be one of the strongest
hurricanes to hit anywhere in louisiana
since
at least the 1850s
louisiana's governor is warning of the
danger to come as preparations in his
state are underway people are filling up
sandbags in an effort to protect their
homes and there are lines at gas
stations as people fill up and head away
from the coast
tomorrow is the 16th anniversary of
hurricane katrina that deadly storm made
landfall as a category 5 and caused more
than 1800 deaths and 125 billion dollars
in damage well a summer of record heat
and drought conditions have fueled
deadly wildfires through much of western
north america and the impact on the
physical environment is extending to
wildlife as well in california there's
been a devastating effect on salmon rob
malcolm explains
the blistering heat wave in california
drought is now to blame for not only
wildfires and farming losses but it's
also wiping out fish in record numbers
the situation's bad what's happening in
northern california rivers is the water
is too hot
to allow
adult salmon coming back
to reproduce this year thousands of
salmon are dying as water levels inch
lower and temperatures in rivers around
california continue to rise
we have four
unique runs of chinook salmon that are
native to the sacramento valley
thousands of young salmon have died in
the klamath river as drought conditions
fueled parasite growth and in the
sacramento river wildlife officials are
now saying they are facing a complete
loss of young chinook salmon due to
abnormally warm water the headline is
that
they are very close to extinction not
likely to survive the migration from the
rivers to the ocean on their own the
california department of fish and
wildlife has stepped in loading young
salmon onto trucks and driving hours to
release them into the ocean the solution
is to put them in tanker trucks give
them a ride down to the ocean and let
them go and that's what occurred this
year although the biggest impact has
been on young salmon adult salmon
haven't gone untouched many of the adult
salmon that have come back are already
dying before they can even spawn
of those that are able to spawn their
eggs which are buried in gravel
underneath the river are dying in river
water because the river water is getting
too hot i don't know 13 pound average
maybe for fisherman larry collins what's
happening has a direct impact on his
ability to put food on his table and
yours i got fish that go to farmers
markets restaurants like that the
industry alone in california is worth
1.4 billion dollars with thousands of
salmon now dying fewer will make it to
store shelves down the line driving
prices higher and that sticker shock is
already setting in
the implications of global warming
threatening to disrupt sensitive
ecosystems and wipe out entire salmon
species in california potentially having
far-reaching consequences rob malcolm
global news sacramento
that is global national for this
saturday night i'm robin gill tonight
your canada is a beautiful sunrise taken
from prince edward island national park
we'd love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
favorite photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you